hi everyone this is another episode in
the story of designing multi-computation
capabilities in wolf language
and
uh let's see what we started off with
trace graph which we talked about last
time is this new material for tracecraft
yep so last time tracecraft didn't work
in all situations and now it does
okay so i can write run the code should
i run this code
okay
okay so here
what am i seeing here so this is
this is a pure
drilling exercise basically there's no
evaluation here is that correct yep
okay
so if i were to just do
all right so if i say trace graph
let's just start a new thing here
i'm just trying to understand and maybe
maybe you've already got this but if i
say trace graph
of
f of abc
okay
so let me try to understand what this is
doing this is saying this is the drill
down
this is the evaluation
red means
that is the result of evaluation is that
correct
yep
does red mean it's a fixed point
no red means that that expression does
not need to do any subsidiary
evaluations
okay
i see but then then that is a reassembly
arrow there
is that correct
correct
okay nick do you have any comments on
this is this consistent with the kind of
way you're doing it or is this quite
different from the way you're doing it
well the way
this is doing it is actually
how they were later doing it
it's doing it i'm doing it just by
looking up down value subfiles and so on
directly
so can i see your version of this thing
that um uh hold on let me just save this
in the right place
um
where do i want to save this
do i save it under notes under meetings
here or do i save it under sw notes
uh you can save it under sw nuts
okay all right
okay so nick do you have an analog of
this
i don't know because
i only
mutilate only concerned with actual
evaluation and i don't have
just this pure drilling down an
expression steps
so if you were to do this
what you would do for this is you would
simply say
if i were to
take your multi-evaluate which of course
is doing a multi-version of things
um
if i were to take multi oh whoops
wow it's complicated okay
so let's uh multi-evaluate
here and i say f of abc
this would do something completely
trivial
it's just not gonna do anything
because
okay but so if i were to do this so let
me let me understand this so if i had to
do
one plus one here
oh this is it's also not going to do
anything because plus
doesn't have any values associated with
it i say so your your thing is dealing
with
down value defined values
not down code
yeah yeah you can provide don't it's
like a separate pattern as an option
what kind of sub-expression to evaluate
okay but in your case what you're saying
is
you've got you've defined plus x blank y
blank
colon equals and now there's the down
down value there and if i now do this
p l u s
of one two
is there is there a graphical
representation that you have of this
yeah just
comma tree or graph
in quotes
okay
and now graph will do the the we'll have
an event there presumably
no i don't have events
it's just
basically gonna duplicate some
expressions
okay but so this here if i were to do
this and i would just say plus
of two comma three
i don't understand this why didn't that
go another level
why didn't that go down to you
you should specify how many steps you
got because this is not a fixed point
so like two steps
so
should it have gone down another level
why didn't that go to fixed points
it is a fixed point because plus doesn't
have any down values again
what do you mean
oh you mean that plus doesn't have down
so
what is this thing down here this is the
capital plus
yeah that's the capital plus
but why doesn't the capital plus just
evaluate to to you know to six here
because i don't want it to without my
permission
okay
if i i have an option that's like
evaluate pattern
and you can say evaluate pattern
blank plus
then it will evaluate all the process
too
i see okay okay so what this is showing
is this is a multi-evaluation so this is
saying you can either go and resolve the
one plus or you can resolve that that
second plus there
and in this case those get to the same
result
so in the graph case i would
de-duplicate that
and it would show confluent behavior
basically
right
right
okay
so what you're emphasizing is
you
don't have in if if you were doing
single way evaluation do you have a path
graph
yeah
always whereas ian does not have a path
graph
because he's actually showing drill down
inside the expression
is that correct right yeah yes
okay now ian doesn't have
multi-evaluation possibilities right
correct trace graph is just the standard
evaluator
okay
and
what was the thing just yesterday where
we were oh yeah we were talking about
traversal order
in the case of map yeah okay fine
okay all right so let's take a look
let's understand okay so this is
next
multi-evaluation
um
okay
so now here
let's take a look at this
okay so these are
those are the drill down arrows
those are the evaluation arrows
these are the reassembly arrows
so that that graph is a trivial
evaluation but if you look at the one
above there are non-highlighted dashed
edges
and those are transformation rules
we mean non-highlighted dashed edges
so like from the y to the x
okay the one to the one and the f to the
g okay so i mean if i might say so
i graphically this is sort of the wrong
way around because the action is being
you know shown as almost nothing and the
inaction is being shown as a big thing
if that makes sense
that's just a minor point
but the action here that's an event
in in next terminology that's an event
there correct
whereas all this drill down is not an
event
right
right so
if this was a token event graph we would
have an event node in the middle of
these is that correct nick
yeah right that's cool
okay so i mean just you know in terms of
the presentation here can you make a big
thick yellow thing that indicates
something happened here
all right what i'm saying i mean just
just so we understand what's going on um
and in a sense
one color for those edges rather than
just flipping the
highlighted and non-highlighted that we
have yeah it doesn't make any sense to
do that i mean we want you know i want
to see where was an event right because
what's going to happen is when we go to
multi-computation to multi-evaluation
we're going to have parallel events
and so do you actually want an
additional node there
i'm not sure probably yes but i'm not
sure yet
okay for now let's not do that
i think
i'll just style it differently yeah big
thick orange thing you know
um
okay
but again i'm already confused again
because red is a is an action color
and this is an inaction node right this
is a node which doesn't change anymore
correct
that's a frozen node that does not
change anymore correct or not correct
it doesn't mean that it won't change it
means that it doesn't need to do
sub-evaluations
okay it's the end of the line in terms
of drill down
but you see that's not right because
that's all end of the line in terms of
drill down
right there
that's that finished drill don't want to
do any sub-evaluations because it's
going to apply a transformation rule no
no no no no no no we're not getting this
right look look there's two different
actions there's drill down and there's
and there's transformation
right
okay so i want to know there is one
thing is you reach the bottom of okay so
normally we do transformation first and
then we continue drill down is that
right
in the event
you do drill down and then
transformation
okay so fine so then to say
this
this is very very confusing and not
right
this is look this reached the end of the
line in terms of drill down here
correct or not correct
correct it's done with drill down okay
so why isn't it red
if you're telling me that red means it's
done with drill down it should be red
here
great
okay
and then it has an event
that transforms it
and then when it returns something
again
there really should be an additional
node for the i guess red is
both
no further drill down and
this is from a previous drill down
that's not good enough right that's
going to confuse things we've got to
break it apart to the absolute minimal
thing right no combined colors
okay
we we have to the whole point is we're
trying to get this so that every step is
separately represented so that we can
see what the multi-way version of it is
makes sense
yep
so let's not combine anything so here
for example i don't understand why that
x doesn't have an additional node
for well no that x is an end of line
okay so we just got the x
and now the next action is is there
drill down for the x and the answer is
no
right
right that's the first thing it's going
to do is try drill down and it can't do
it so you don't drill down in atoms
i understand but then why is this
showing a one goes to one that's not
right either it's got to show an x goes
to x or it shouldn't show a one goes to
one
well so the
the
the highlighted dashed edges
are for expressions that evaluate
directly to themselves
they're represented as a singleton in
the output of trace i've only split them
into two kinds i don't care what the
output of trade is i mean trace was
something we designed in 1990 it's been
a flop
so we're not basing what we're doing on
trace we're trying to actually get it
right
so the fact that tracer lighted things
well my point is i'm not making any
decisions based on what trace does it so
the thing is i'm choosing to represent
an expression that evaluates to itself
as two different nodes just so that you
see the node flipping from one color to
another
arguably that's not necessary yeah i
don't think it's the right thing to do
and the reason i brought up trace was
because trace doesn't do that so
i see okay but but but so again again i
want to understand because you know in
the analogy of physics project stuff
okay
okay
in the physics project in a token event
graph okay there is no drill down in the
physics project
because the physics project is using
hypergraphs that are one level
are making sense
other people nick and so on understand
that right
there
um
and so what we're doing there
is we are taking
we have a bag of tokens which is the
hypograph
and we are then picking out
in some cases pairs of tokens now
in the evaluator we don't we never pick
pairs of tokens we never do the thing
that the physics project does is that a
true statement
nick you you and other people you
understand what i'm saying in the
physics project we we will in a token
event graph we will be picking
two different
pieces
um oh we have jonathan here as well
jonathan has opinions about all of this
um
everybody's very silent
okay they
okay my understanding is that that's
correct
like your your root your transformation
rules
get applied to
an expression in trace graph instead of
you know
a collection of tokens
right nick do you want to comment on
that
yeah it's only a single token or
sub-expression that always gets
evaluated in the
usual trace
right like for example for woofer model
we have
a rules that act on different hyper
edges
so it's like a multi
sub-expression evaluation
well so what you're identifying is we've
got two kinds of multi going on
right one
uh
you know
one is
multiple possible events
from a single expression
and we're doing all of them and the
other is
a
events
that have
multiple token inputs
which is something which is not present
is that true that that's not present i
mean obviously you can write it
trivially with pattern matching in the
language
but the evaluator is not intrinsically
dealing with that
that makes sense
so i mean that's another way in which we
could generalize the evaluator but it's
not the one we were thinking of so far
is that right
yeah i don't think that we've
specifically mentioned this
in terms of generalizing the evaluator
okay i suppose another way you could
talk about that is you could say that
you want
sort of rewrites to
whether or not a rewrite can be applied
depends on multiple kind of non-local
parts of the expression tree exactly
right which is not what we normally have
normally rewrites the local
this is effectively
normally the rewrite is for the entire
expression tree
right right right right ie
rewrites
not applied purely to subtrees
so in a sense that's another specialness
of the evaluator that we have right now
is that it is a pure gulper hole subtree
evaluator
so i if i can make it just a purely
pragmatic comment so in um
convert it so for functions like find
wolf and model proof that take
hypergraph transformation rules of the
kind using the physics project and
convert them into things that can be
sort of
over which one can do theorem proving
using the standard wl evaluator
uh the way that that's done
which may or may not be optimal but
almost certainly isn't um is that each
there's a composition operation on the
hyper edges in effect composition
operation on the on the sub trees that's
assumed to obey commutation to to obey
community uh commutativity
and that commutativity operation that
lets you effectively do this non-local
rewriting
okay so wait a minute so basically what
you're saying is
you you pick the things you pick those
sub expressions up
you make them into a super expression
on which you then do rewriting
right right
okay so that is another stage so a way
can be looked at
as
an additional stage
which is collect
collect the sub-trees
into a single tree
then rewrite
right right and again the the fact that
the ordering of hyperedges doesn't
matter is just stating that essentially
that collection operation is algebra you
know it's commutative
yeah right
um
right
often consider order not to matter
although i'm not sure that that's um
uh i mean i don't think that's a
necessarily an absolutely
yeah i'm not sure that that's a
necessary feature
well no i mean obviously for a full
evaluator you wouldn't want that to be
the case
right
that's that's peculiar to the hypograph
case
okay
so
all right
so let's go back maybe and look at so i
mean just in terms of where we're trying
to go with this again
the
the big picture is
we are
okay again i think we'd summarize this
last time so let me go back to that for
a second
to make sure we don't we don't
um
confuse ourselves
let's see
if you want to go to multi-computation
and then meetings and notes
last week's detailed notes would be in
there if that's what you're looking for
okay i think i'm also looking for
okay
so these are
graph evaluation technologies okay
yeah this is what i wanted to do this is
what i want to talk about um
this whole idea which i've been through
many many times now
of in the multi-evaluator
you know again we we want to do this
thing where we say essentially
multi-evaluate
of expert
and it produces
a some kind of
computation object
or something
and that that thing
is a lazily computed could be infinite
could be non-terminating
and then
we can ask of that computation object we
can say
eg
you
know uh
find a path
from you know expert to expert two
right that's essentially theorem proving
that's essentially they're improving the
you know question right which is which
is otherwise known as find replace path
right that's that's one type of thing
another type of thing would be
find
um
an output that satisfies
uh
a given condition find an intermediate
step that satisfies a given condition
immediate step
or an output
in the multi-way thing that satisfies a
given condition
it makes sense
that's like optimization
yep
another thing would be
uh kind of find the probability
for
a particular output
or one satisfying um
or one satisfying condition
okay so that's like probabilistic
programming and then there's you know
question mark path counting and so on
how you do the path counting but that's
basically that so a sub case of that or
the kind of hash p computation
um
of count the number of outputs of that
type
so actually you know in a sense
i think this is like np computation is
that right
and this is i mean i think you can think
of these in terms of computational
complexity classes to some extent
anybody got any more thoughts about that
anyway so look this is the kind of thing
we're trying to do right does this make
sense to people
and i mean another thing we're trying to
get as output is a graph that represents
the multi-evaluator the result of
multi-evaluation to some level
that makes sense
okay but we have that to some degree
already the nix function i know it's
just not not finished i mean that that's
the point we're we're getting there
we're trying to we're trying to figure
out what we're doing there we don't have
the whole thing because we don't have
something which runs to the conceptual
fixed point which may not exist
you know if i if i run multi-evaluate on
the s combinator with some complicated
initial string it's not going to
terminate yeah right so what do we do
right and that's the easiest approach
yeah right right but we have to know
what what it is we're trying to extract
from it right
and for that
you know
when there is a fixed point when there
is a single fixed point
we don't care about traversal order
well we might care we don't care about
traversal order except for efficiency
right but in the case where there isn't
a single fixed point we absolutely do
care about traversal order
we care about which foliation we're
looking at we're going to get a
different answer that's right
okay so one question i have is with the
version of multievaluate that nick's
sharing with us
it only goes to a fixed point
like the addition
actually evaluates when nick basically
permits it to do so manually
so if this is going to work in general
how do we overcome this obstacle where
we're
letting it evaluate by specifying that
it can do so manually
well okay hold on hold on so the
question is what can be in okay so so
what can be in exper in multi-evaluate
okay okay okay
so clearly
you know by hand transformation rules
are fair game
right we know we're gonna have those
we also want to have
uh built-in evaluation rules
built-in transformation rules so the
question is how do we represent those
in
an i claim a built-in transformation
rule is like you know for theorem
proving it's like what do they call it
hammers or so i don't know what they
call it you know it's something where
you kind of
you know you're just jumping to the
answer
right with a built-in transformation
rule now there may be a more complicated
case
okay so here's an example
of a
okay so the intermediate case
is
so a built-in transformation rule like
one plus one goes to two
we think that's a fairly safe thing to
put in there
okay however
let's say
it is a sandwich
of
rules
eg
you know nest of f comma whatever where
the f
where f
has
by hand transformations
okay is that making sense yeah
so that is reminiscent to me of things
that we have in neural nets where we've
got some meta operator
anybody want to comment on this so this
is the case with nick do you have you
thought about this case
and is this what's holding you up
because i mean you know by hand
transformation rules we understand how
that's going to work
yeah
and and the second case here if you just
say
it's done in one step we understand how
that can work too right
yeah we can in principle
our
additional downwards basically that's
that's what it is
well yes but it's it's when it's a
built-in transformation rule it's just
like you just run the code
yeah right i mean in other words if it
i see so the way we would do this is
there is no user code that is run
automatically
it is only run in the harness of
multi-evaluate
but the question of whether the built-in
code runs automatically is its own
question
and now we've got the sandwich cases
hey does christopher for example have
any opinion about this about this
concept of the
or anybody else here
by by hand do you mean
you would give a list of rules as
another argument in multi-evaluate well
that's a possibility
e.g
or do you mean no i i that was well
defined right eg from an explicit list
of rules
or from down value assignments
well
can we just say like symbol definitions
to be
complete
yeah okay that's just one kind of
definition
okay
okay so i i think that's one of the
things yeah go ahead
well
one of the things we talked about a
while ago was sort of but i'm not sure
it can actually work
um was something where
basically you'd write sort of a normal
program and then every so often maybe
you could use some construct like i
don't know what to call it let's say
like multi or something you'd say multi
of you know and then you you give it a
couple of arguments and then effectively
that would be you know a point where the
program would sort of branch and it
would you know you could think of it as
non-deterministically choosing you know
one of the arguments there
um
but i don't know there were sort of lots
of issues with this like the fact that
you know if you're using this inside of
say a module then the module variables
you know as it goes through the
different branches of the multi it
somehow needs to be able to you know
reset the module variables and so on
because you know if if one branch
changes the variables then when it runs
the next branch it'll be all messed up
and so
yeah
that that's exactly um uh
nick's canonicalization
of bound variables stuff isn't it
nick can you comment on that
that's exactly when when you have a
multi-way system
and it has generated variables on
different branches that's the question
of canonicalizing the variables on
different branches i think
the thing christopher just described
well if it evaluates in different
branches it may as well
evaluate independently so i don't see an
issue
at all
no because the problem is that if you
have an outer module like if you set a
variable x and then in one branch it's
going to reset x to 12 and the other
branch it's going to reset x to 15
right then
if you run the first depending on the
order in which you happen to run the
branches you know you might you might
get sort of weird uh conflicts
oh yeah you should maintain the state so
each of those branches should have a
state
right right i think that there is there
is no
there's no easy way in the language
right now of being able to represent the
state right because it's just like the
whole symbol table
right and you'd have to branch it by a
sub module that has its own separately
named x i think
right
from a programming perspective if you
know if you know about this issue it's
not hard to just basically
basically make sure you don't do any
closures this is effectively what this
is
um
but
but i'm not sure you can really trust
people to to know that
right
how do you get a dingbat i always forget
this and oh it's a star right
no how do you get how do you get a star
what do you do in a bullet it's a star
you type a star in yourself
what
in a text cell
where is it
i think it's a
i mean first of all you just there we go
i got it i got it i got it got it got it
yeah okay all right so the first first
way to specify maltiness is an explicit
list
of rules
that will be used
at each step
that can be reused
no can be can be
tried can be
an explicit list of rules can be tried
yeah yeah it can be tried at each step
that's one form of multiness
and that's what we were imagining in eg
find replace path that was what we were
imagining it was going to do
makes sense
and that is also
how the automated theorem prover will
work if i'm not mistaken without any
hammering right if you you know the
standard automatic theorem prover what
would we what what is this this is
essentially find equational proof here
am i right
yeah can i make a comment regarding that
so in terms of the built-in
transformation rules
one thing that would be really
convenient for theorem improving is if
we are going to have those that we have
that one has essentially fine-grained
control over which ones get applied and
which don't if that makes sense
yes
right you want you want your theorem
improvement to be able to say yes i can
use the fact that addition is
commutative but i can't use the fact
that you know i can't use this
complicated theorem from analysis or
something
um
where you know where the the evaluator
might treat both of those things as
being somehow on the same level
otherwise yeah no i understand i mean
that's a huge can of worms that was a
gosh that was a thing in smp again where
i had names for all the transformation
rules that were built in
which we gave up on here but yes i
understand so
so
okay so another thing is
um
so okay so
uh
you know
okay so adding
built-in
transformations
so now the question is how does that
work so the question would be which
transformations can you use
which transformations can be used
and then what happens in in the sandwich
case
in the callback sandwich case
because in other words in other words in
a sense find replace path
is a sandwich but its only sandwich
operator is composition
am i right there
people understand what i'm saying so in
other words
do you mean that you're using
built-in system
definitions as well as users yes i mean
a sandwich i mean something like nest
where the function that is being used in
nest here
is something that
is a
has user definitions
okay so the whole point is that that you
should see
you know
in other words okay so the basic point
is there's controlled stuff in
f has
sort of controlled pieces
but they are being
sort of
bank used
by nest is that making any sense i mean
it's just like in a neural net where you
have something where you have one of the
meta operators for neural nets
that's saying use this network in a
recurrent way or something
well okay let's talk about multi for a
second maybe that will make this clearer
okay so then there's multi
and
oh gosh you see there's other cases here
because
okay there's another case which is
um
uh
sort of do
evaluation of arguments
in any order
that's another multiness
so in other words
do you mean
yeah go ahead does that like the
argument concurrent attribute
i don't know oh yes yes yes right
exactly yes
well no but that doesn't affect the
output you get really i mean assuming
that there isn't like crazy race
conditions or assuming you wrote your
program correctly that doesn't affect
the output it just affects the internals
of how it's done but it does affect the
multi-array graph
right why
because i mean you're just you just need
output assuming
there's a fixed point
but like isn't this just if you look at
like uh you know if you look at uh say
the the trace trace graph right i mean
it's just it's just that
you know there there's all of the the
drill down edges all of that attribute
means is that you do all the drill down
edges at the same time in different
threads as opposed to
as opposed to doing them sequentially
but it doesn't actually change the graph
right
yeah i guess that's right
but
yes okay fine fine yeah okay
right okay so it doesn't affect does not
affect the evaluation graph
i guess it would if you had some shared
variables and you wrote your program
poorly
but only
yeah assuming no side effects
well mutually graph still gonna have
branches
yes
but but the branches will be the same
but but wait a minute but only
the foliation used
i mean like
each branching evaluates arguments
they like separately now we just
evaluate each argument individually
yes
so they're different
right
yeah go ahead sorry i was just going to
say this is probably a question for a
different time but is there an argument
given this to have a finer grained
version of a multi-way evolution graph
in which effectively each edge is not an
individual evaluation of an argument but
an evaluation of all arguments in in
some sub-expression that leads to a
fixed point so that the only branches
are genuine branches of non-determinism
wait a minute so you're saying
i mean this is this would be the full
expression analog of a generational
multi-way system
in which so a generational by
generational you mean that the whole
sub-expression has been reassembled
that's what you mean by a generation so
if you've got a you know you you you
have some sub expression that's you know
f of a b c d
uh and you know that that you know the
evaluation of that sub expression
reaches a fixed point then rather than
having you know individual paths started
for evaluating a b c or d initially you
just evaluate the whole thing to that
fixed point and treat that as a single
edge
right but that is that is basically if
i'm understanding correctly that is
generational that that's saying it's a
multi-wave system where where every step
is a generational step
right right
right so so this is the but the thing is
with with generational multi-way systems
you would
you know as with all multi-way systems
we kind of don't worry about whether the
thing reaches a fixed point or not
whereas you know if you want to turn
this into a practical evaluator you you
would have to
i'm not buying the fact that the
evaluator has a fixed point
that's the point
i'm not claiming the evaluator has to
have a fixed point i'm saying that if
you want to do reasoning over these
things whether whether the individual
sub tree over which you're evaluating
has a fixed point or not matters
because you know if again if you take
the combinations example if you want to
if you want to reason about intermediate
expressions
uh then it matters whether the whether
the subject you know whether the subtree
you're applying things to is going to
terminate or not because the you know
the confluence properties will be
different in that case
okay but but so what what you're saying
is
is there a larger lump multi-way system
in which okay so this is
in which
you can you
you
uh
aggregate congeal what's the right word
you you um not quite conflate in which
you
you pull together
um
sort of
sub pieces
of the multi-way graph
that
well essentially correspond to drill
down is that right
correspond to
roughly that roughly correspond to drill
down
um
all right let's
let me just try to understand
the the multi-concept for a second
because i think that might be helpful
okay so what does multi do so multi
says
what would be an example of where one
would use multi what one one just says
once reached this point in the
computation and
you say you either do f of x or you do g
of x here is that right
yeah so you just say you know multi of f
of x comma g of x
right which is and so in that sense so
cf
you know
abc
a b
whoops
a b has a and b space like separated
multi of a b
has a and b branch-like separated
i think that's what we're claiming and
and so then the idea is
that this is a way of putting together
so
in
in ian's pictures no not even ian's
pictures in nick's pictures
oh this is so confusing
is that a more granular way to write
this branching
that we could say this thing evaluates
to multi of this and this
see i think multi is going to get
confused because i think
it has to have a foliation
oh it's to to say
okay okay so let's put it different
different way
you know
as we do a computation
we reassemble things into spatial pieces
which thing is like consider combinators
and consider some multi-way graph of
combinator evaluations
the assembly of a particular complete
combinator expression
will get a different expression
yeah i mean it's until we get to a fixed
point there's no guarantee that we'll
have
you know one of these expressions could
have this part not yet evaluated and the
other parts evaluated or something
different
that's right
and so
both the spatial and the branch hill
sort of intermediate steps depend on
foliation
and the question is is it useful what we
are doing right now
is
we are very fixed point thinkers so to
speak
and so
we take
you know we think there's a spatial we
think there's a reality to the spatial
version of expressions
even though in in
in fact if we had a multi-way evaluator
there wouldn't be a reality to the
intermediate expressions
that making sense in other words that
the fact that there exists ever abcd in
the intermediate step it might be
fictional
because if we're doing it where do you
if if you need this foliation but where
is it specified then in the version
where you just give a list of
replacement rules
um
well the whole point is that that in
that you can never really ask what the
intermediate expressions are
because with a set of replacement rules
you could have applied rules one two
five you could have reply applied one
one seven five one two
you know you could have applied them in
different orders every branch applies
them in a different order
um
and uh
um
well usually you you can ask what the
intermediate expressions are but you'll
just get a branch your graph
you'll get a branch of graph right but
you'll have a you'll have many different
possible intermediate expressions
right it isn't
there isn't whereas okay in the
evaluator right now
okay i mean our evaluator has just a
particular set of intermediate
expressions that correspond to its
particular traversal order and it's
particular can you open the sections for
hold attributes and non-standard
evaluation
yeah
cause i think viewing it as a traversal
order might be too
uh restricted
oh gosh really
what should i be looking at well let's
non-standard evaluation here
right so here we're seeing subsidiary
evaluations
that are not just traversing the
expression that you started with okay
that's what i've been calling sandwiches
over here
i think
in other words there's a control of the
evaluation
that is happening through a built-in
function
that isn't just defined by a generic
multi-way graph
so for example look at the very last
step you have two
which is the result of u equals two and
then null which is the result of the do
and then 256
which is the result of u
and this recombination edge unlike the
ones above that we're just building an
expression compound expression has a
special way of reconstructing this
the last thing right that's special
deconstruction and reconstruction
right that is sandwiching and my i mean
i don't not a very good word for it but
you get what i'm saying that's something
where
yes where there's an over there's a
there's an overarching control okay so
my claim is
that the pure case
of you've given a list of transformation
rules
has a default way of of deconstructing
and reconstructing
that is a sentence
and that's
and can you scroll down to the agenda
for the evaluator style replace
or yeah
this is just some basic code that
is the basic idea of how the evaluator
does its traversal
what should i see here
i think you should read the code
like the
like so you're taking a fixed point of
repeatedly applying rules but the way
you apply the rules
is by
evaluating the parts at level one and
then applying rules to the thing you get
right in other words that's just saying
a non-held
function a non-hold function evaluates
its head and its arguments and then
tries to evaluate the whole thing yep
and then it does a fixed point of that
operation
yes so this is the
okay but the whole point is this thing
evaluate the head evaluate the arguments
and sequence
that is precisely a particular foliation
of this multi-way evaluation
because that's the thing which if we had
multiple threads running we could
evaluate the arguments in different
orders
that's a particular order where you're
going essentially left to right
and in the case of non-standard
evaluation you can have completely
arbitrary
expressions to be evaluated and
arbitrary right
while we're on this while we're on this
borderline observer theoretic
thread here i wanted to mention nick i
don't know for comfortable discussing it
yet but nick did mention to me that he
has an idea for
um
equipping
multi-evaluate with the ability to also
you know you can specify the kind of
search like breadth first or depth first
and so it can kind of impose some sort
of ordering
as it's as it's performing the
multi-evaluation this is kind of fresh i
don't think it's been developed yet but
maybe we could discuss it but that's
that's essentially saying look
one thing is in this model where
multi-evaluate returns a computation
object that's a lazy thing
what what i think you're saying there is
what does the front look like
you know a multi-evaluate if you're
doing breadth first
it will have a particular front as it
goes you know multi-evaluate as it as it
iterates through what it's doing right
it's going to have a certain front of
its depth first to have a different
front
yeah
is that right nick
oh yeah right now it's just
just breath first which way it evaluates
all the sub-expression and breadth first
order
right but so you in principle you could
use ian's traversal order mechanism
possibly even very directly in the i
mean if we had a traversal order for map
you might be able to plug that in very
easily to your code
well not necessarily but yeah it's easy
because it's
as soon as i have a list of expressions
in its positions i can sort them by
whatever order
i provide it
so
pointing out is
like with tree traversal order there are
traversal orders that are not defined by
sorting the positions like leaves first
right
and that might be just totally
uninteresting
for not sure no i don't think it's
necessarily uninteresting
i think
you need it to be
you need the entire multi-way system to
be finite
to be able to do a leaves i see i see i
see which we probably don't have that
okay but but so look in terms of what we
want to do here
seems to me why don't we develop
something where we are giving explicit
lists of rules why don't we why don't we
make sure we can really do that case and
why don't we build the functions around
that case like find replace path because
one of the things if i'm understanding
correctly the explicit list of rules
okay that that would be the case that we
need well but they're improving with
traditional theorem proving techniques
we need two-way rules
correct well that's what we've been
using
it depends what you mean by traditional
theorem improving techniques
explain
well there are improving techniques like
paramodulation that require two-way
rules there are others like resolution
which don't
they're both traditional um
it's been around for about half a
century
right
well okay so
okay but then so what i'm suggesting is
can we get a version of
you know
okay whether it's multi-evaluate and
then you do things to its lazy
computation object whether they are
particular functions like find replace
path you know we've got a version of
find replace both we have multiple
versions but can we please just like try
and finish that off in other words try
and try and work through the cases for
explicitly given rules
which is more similar to what we've done
in the physics project
then we've got the separate issue
of dealing with the interaction with our
built-in evaluator technology
am i making sense
nick do you understand what i'm saying
here
yeah
yeah
so
the things you've got right now
how much does your multi-evaluate
basically do i mean you've got these
different cases of what you're trying to
get out
right can we do that from your
multi-evaluate or not
what different cases well i mean things
like
the the find replace path right just
find a path from here to there i don't
think you can do that from this yet this
this is
just evaluate and generate the whole
multi-way graph is that a correct
statement
well it depends how efficient you want
one to be it's like in order to make it
into a
semi-efficient
base path function you just need some
kind of selection right so that you
don't ex not exploring every branch sure
sure absolutely and we had a couple of
implementations six months ago i'll find
replace path that for example went you
know knows it's going from the input
and it's coming you know and it then is
is the the past like kind of the output
and so on it's trying to look at the
the overlap between those two things i
mean we just need an efficient version
of that and that efficient version
should be essentially the theorem prover
shouldn't it
am i confused there i mean isn't that
what a theorem proverb is basically
yeah it's just not
usually doing it like that like
future and past entertainment con and
intersect and tries to find the
intersection
right
because
you know you can't usually
go backwards well you can if you have
two-way rules
oh yeah
right
the the the very first prototype version
that i made of find replace path and
find string replace path did exactly
this i know i know i know i know
right so i mean i'm i'm saying
let's have a version of find replace
path that is efficient as efficient as
it can be given that if it has two-way
rules it can do the forward-backward
thing if it has one-way rules it can't
do that it has to have some other
selection criteria and so on
but but then
the thing is that find replace path as
we know from the very beginning of how
we were doing this
one thing we can do is just give the
path
the other thing we can do is
you know there are elementary things
like the length of the path the question
is there a path right is this a possible
output does a path exist
you know other things are the path
together with some stubs
of the bronchial pieces
which i think was also useful
another
question is just find me a path any path
another is find me the shortest path
get what i'm saying
i mean what this is what we want to do
to you know this is a style of
programming is i've just got a bunch of
transformations and i want to find
things out you know the things that we
just listed here
right this this type of thing
right so in other words
case number one is we've got a list of
rules
one-way or two-way rules
and we want to do these kinds of operant
we want to answer these kinds of
questions for them does that make sense
i think nick i think this is kind of in
your
area because i think this is basically
you know sort of generalizations of
multi-evaluate
oh i can imagine it was as having a
muchy object that you can query
query with all those different questions
and it's like
it's like you're constructing an
observer and you just
it's some kind of agent that tries to
target this multi object
and it sounds great
searches for things in it
itself is lazy lazy thing that just
doesn't have anything it just constructs
a history of
i don't know it's it's maybe it's uh
some
interaction between this observer and
the mutual object maybe there are
different kind of things that we have to
construct
yes
i mean
right so in other words you could
potentially have a symbolic
representation of the observer which
itself has operations done so
multi-evaluate going to multi-object
can do some transformation
that makes sense
it does pre-processing so that the
multi-object isn't just raw
redoing everything there
does that make sense which object is
like an environment
that your observer is exploring
well fine but then the observer itself
could have something where
it
uh
what am i trying to say whether where
you can
compute on the observer and pre-process
the observer
just like you can pre-process the
environment
okay but look this is the thing we know
we need
okay
so that's sort of step one is we know we
need these different cases of this
and
you know so i think that's something we
should build now
now
the next question is so this is using
by hand transformation rules just from
our pattern matcher
and i mean one point to make there is
uh replace list already does is the core
operation there that basically does you
know enumerates the cases am i making
sense
right
well mutually it already uses the voice
list
underneath yeah and i understand that
but that's that's the core thing that is
multi
that's the that's the lowest level
multiplication so to speak that has to
be done without with pure by hand
transformation rules
what is less clear is how to do the
multiplication when it isn't just to
listen okay so look look
the you know
uh
generating
multiplication
okay so one method is use replace list
and that's what's going to be good for
explicit lists of rules
okay the next case is
uh that you are trying to do it
um doing it from
built-in data structures
eg
eg a list
right where the multiplication is you
can evaluate the elements of the list in
any order
by making sense
see what i'm saying
i mean in other words that's a different
thing
right did you understand what i'm saying
anybody understand what i'm saying
this is a way if you want to know what
are all possible branches
right one way you can do it is you use a
replaced list and you use the fact that
a rule can be applied in multiple ways
or multiple rules can be applied in
multiple ways
the question is what are the other ways
in which there are multiple branches
one other way in which there's a
multiple branch i think is that a list
can have its elements evaluated in any
order
basically or even just any any
expression
yes can be evaluated in yes yes exactly
but the point is that that that's and
and sometimes okay so my point is
the difference between so we've got this
case where we've got by hand rules
specified
okay
and
that's a case where we think we
understand what we're gonna do do we
understand what we're gonna do here
do we understand this this stuff here
yes nick i think that's that's for you
basically
well
it
has all this smoothiness already it's
just not in this lazy fashion
well you know but it doesn't have the
ability to say find a path from here to
that that's what we need does it or does
it have that
does it have that or not
no it's just well
if it's easy to add a selection function
it's kind of already
some kind of criteria when how to find
stuff
yeah okay fair enough but i mean so what
it's doing right now is generating the
graph correct basically
it's generating the the data for the
graph for the complete graph okay so now
we are doing the filtering by the
observer of that graph
and as you say it will be much more
efficient if it is not generating the
whole graph but it's doing so lazily
yeah and some with some other specified
and other tricks
yes i know but that's that's going to be
you know that is for the observer that
is a foliation
taken by the observer on the multi-way
system
right
okay
so now
that's the case for by hand rules
okay the next case we're we're
interested in
is the case where
where there is something that where we
have
not just a bag of rules that are being
applied and by the way with a bag of
rules at each step we're just doing
slash dot
let's see do we have any drill down
issues there
no the rules are being applied to whole
expressions aren't they
it's replace
right yeah it's replaced right so that
that's the case here the simplest case
um
yeah replace list right right right
right so the simplest case all right so
look drill down
simplest case
pure replace list
ie
whole expression replacement
okay
next case
some form
of drill down
or sandwich
okay so drill down
is the pure
you know recursion as ian has indicated
it over here the pure recursion into an
expression done by the evaluator
drill down wherever
this example here
drill down sorry sandwiching is more
like this kind of operation
so in other words the one operation
which you are indicating in these graphs
is the pure drill down
you know that this is i don't know where
there was an example of one but you know
the pure drill down which you had up
above here
whatever it is there's there's pure
drill down into an expression like this
one here makes sense
yep
and then there is what we're calling
sandwich which isn't pure drill down
it's something else it's being it's a
controlled way of going through an
expression
or processing an experiment i think it's
basically two different kinds of
deconstruction uh do you deconstruct it
into its parts at level one or do you
deconstruct it into
arbitrary expressions
perhaps yes but i mean in other words
you know or alternatively it is a thing
where it's a pure atomic you know
operation done by the built-in code
that's the whole point you you're
showing here okay so okay
here's the basic question
it could be the case that once you get
into the built-in code there's no
multiness anymore okay so this is a
question
inside the inside
you know built-in code
can there be
multiness
right and and for example eg
nest or nest list or something nest f
comma x comma five
the f there could itself have multi
stuff in it
does that make sense
or we could decide that can't have
anything multi once you go into nest
it's a single atomic operation and
there's no multiness anymore
do you see what i'm saying
i i think it's more like if f
was some kind of operation that involved
multi-computation like it would just be
kind of self-contained it would just i
mean it's just another function just f
like i don't think nest would even treat
it any differently
like if that's not replacing we're
making one of these graphs listen if
we're making a graph that shows the
multi-way graph of what goes on
right there's the question of is this
just a sub graph is the f piece
right in the nest is it just a sub graph
or is there something more complicated
going on
okay because otherwise otherwise it
should be the case that the events that
we produce there could be an event which
just represents that was a built-in
operation and that's the end of the
story that's the only thing that happens
there is a single built-in operation but
in compound expression for example there
isn't just a single you know you see the
the innards of that
do you get what i'm saying
right yeah i understand
so non-standard evaluation you could
have arbitrary expressions and arbitrary
handling of them
yeah exactly so the question is how does
that merge into the multi-way graph and
that's essentially what we're also
asking over here because you've got
drill down how does drill down merge
into the multi-way graph
that makes sense i mean here you've got
a
you know
this is a yet a different case because
this is down values instead of rules
or maybe this was done with rules i'm
not sure
am i making sense i mean this is a
picture that you get by doing the
multi-way graph
from a collection of replaceless applied
rules
that right
looks like
this one is made with the rules here
explicit rules
right okay so my point is if sandwiched
inside here there was a nest operation
what would this look like
see would the nest operation just be a
single event or is there something
inside that
yeah i think you would just see a node
that
has head nest and then
an event and then a new node that
doesn't have the head nest anymore
with no sub detail
if the nest were pure function
then it would be just a another path
because each application of nest is just
another rule
for example if it's nest fx5
it's just getting replaced with
nest f
f x four
and so on
that would be the igo case but if i we
don't have an explicit rule for nice
then i have no idea
wait a minute look look the problem is
we don't have
you know we have a large system
which contains
many black box
essentially laws of inference
that are not we we have laws of
inference that are explicit
or something that are that correspond to
the um
you know what i'm saying to the the the
um
you know to explicitly the difference
between down values and down code
yes
yes or even
like maybe you don't even want to be
able to see
the down values for things that are
defined in top level that are built in
so they're not right right exactly
that's like the debugger that's like the
issue we have with the debugger is what
do you want to see
right so we can have you know the other
case okay so we've got the replaced list
case
we've also got or
we've got down values
either all
or user
supplied
okay and i think that case we should
also try to support because you can get
those down and and maybe you support it
as a practical matter and next is
probably for you by just clearing the
symbol and looking you know by just
looking explicitly at the down values
list
because you don't actually want to use
the evaluator
am i making sense
oh that well
that's really what i'm doing i think i'm
not using evaluator i know you're not i
know you know but i'm saying if i've
defined a fibonacci function f of x
blank colon equals blah blah right but i
want to use your code i would like to be
able to just say
multi-evaluate of f of 7
and not write it out as rules but have
you deal with that
right by by not using but by having it
doesn't you know it doesn't use the
evaluator on f of seven which would use
the down values that have been defined
but instead you use the down values by
hand
do you get what i'm saying yeah that's
what it's doing here
so it's taking the assignments and it's
just using them by hand is that correct
yeah okay fine fine okay but but but we
need those two cases we need either a
case
okay
these two cases are merging into each
other right we have a case where you
give the rules explicitly there's not
using the evaluator at all you have the
case where you're avoiding the evaluator
by
you know just using the rules from the
down values list
right
then we've got the case where there is
no choice but to use the evaluator
because there's nothing there's no
explicit rules because it's in down code
right
so the question is what to do in that
case
and then we've got the sandwich case of
down code where even within the down
code it is calling potentially user
supplied down values
um
well we can always
in case of the down code we can always
just splice this
trace graph
right
between the
when we have to evaluate it what's the
sub expression in order to make the
trace graph you just call trace on the
expression
so
unless you had a way to modify trace
to be multi
i'm not sure how that would work
okay i have to go so
um
uh
you guys could keep going actually if
you wanted to
um
can i ask is a practical thing about
tracecraft i think that that's a fairly
self-contained
function
um
should this at some point be handed off
to the graphs and networks team
they won't do anything with it
it's it's up it's on you okay
okay
i think that we should develop it
further i mean i think we've got some
sort of recoloring to do and so on but i
think you know
it should make it quickly to the
function repository and then from there
into something i mean
look what we need to make it practical
is we need ways to i mean i don't know
whether we want interactive opening of
of things or whether we want more kind
of the programmatic things that we
haven't traced the programmatic things
in trace already useful right so this
this will presumably allow one to trace
only a particular function right
yeah so right now this only is the one
argument form of trace the two argument
form you can give a pattern
i know i know i know so you need a way
to represent
the kind of you know the the um if we
can decide how to hang together like the
sparse like i know i know that's what we
have to do so we should figure that out
because that this will be very useful
for debugging i mean if we and then they
could also support all of the same like
trace above trace below trace ahead
yes i know but each one of those things
it's going to be these different kinds
of look essentially what's happened is
you ripped a piece out of the multi-way
graph actually not even multi-weight
growth out of some kind of valuation off
and it's got these dangling ends to do
with trace above or the fact that it
only saw the f's and not the g's and so
on
and the question is how do we represent
that
how do we represent those dangling ends
make sense yeah and yes we should try
and address that
um
uh
okay let's let's see so any any last
comments here i mean of i mean do we
have a path forward so to speak we know
we want to do the purely explicit not
assignment because that's going to
tangle us up with the evaluator the
non-evaluator you just give rules which
can include two-way rules and then
doing you know the observation of the
two-way rules if you understand what i'm
saying
yes
right
okay anything else that we need to um
uh
i mean look we specified a number of
next steps here i think
what remains to be done which we can do
in the coming days is figure out how
we're going to like
what to do next in terms of the
functionality that's going to address
these multiple different you know next
steps
okay
all right so
fine okay
all right well thanks guys